Jake:就是你如果腰斩的话不就不能播了吗
Lucia: 你好认真的在思索这个可能性
Lucia: You're seriously considering this possibility.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Alice:你真的不把我的命当命
Alice: You really don't value my life.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 太不重视员工的身心健康
Lucia: You don't care about the physical and mental health of your employees.
Jake:嗯那还是暂时暂时
Jake: Hmm, well, let's... let's...
Jake:我们不要腰斩啊
Jake: Let's not cut anyone in half for now.
Jake:这个哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 暂时哈哈
Lucia: For now, haha.
Alice:暂时
Alice: For now.
Lucia: 保留到
Lucia: Keep it until
Lucia: 保留到录制完作为于心节目是吗
Lucia: Keep it until the recording is over, is that right?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈对不起我笑点低哈哈
Lucia: Haha, sorry, I laugh easily, haha
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey
Jake:哎喂
Jake: Hey, hello
Jake:哎我我那个要扫房间
Jake: Hey, I need to clean the room
Jake:然后你你你这个屋子我就这么扫了
Jake: And I'll just clean this room like this
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
Jake:哈哈行行挺有艺术感
Jake: Haha, alright, it looks artistic
Jake:我觉得挺好
Jake: I think it's good
Jake:好嗯拜拜
Jake: Alright, bye
Lucia: 宝你的衣服洗了吗
Lucia: Babe, did you wash your clothes?
Alice:谁呀
Alice: Who?
Lucia: 啊这么快
Lucia: Oh, so fast
Alice:对
Alice: Yes
Lucia: 好的吧
Lucia: Okay
Alice:我其实本来想吃完饭再洗的
Alice: I actually planned to wash them after dinner
Alice:他一直在这催我说我懒
Alice: He kept urging me, saying I'm lazy
其他人：那是自然啊
Others: Naturally
Jake:就已经洗完了嗯
Jake: It's already done, huh
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Lucia: 我在给上面抹洗洁精
Lucia: I'm putting dishwashing liquid on the top
Alice:醉了
Alice: Drunk
Alice:你把这个粉撒到这里面
Alice: You sprinkle this powder in here
Lucia: 要不我还是用洗衣机洗一遍算了
Lucia: Maybe I should just use the washing machine again
Lucia: 因为刚那个掉下来的他
Lucia: Because it fell down just now
Jake:可以对
Jake: Sure
Jake:啊 15分钟不算十
Jake: Ah, 15 minutes is nothing
Jake:十十五分钟算什么
Jake: What is 10-15 minutes?
Lucia: 还可以选择30分钟模式
Lucia: You can also choose the 30-minute mode
Lucia: 相当于你在之前的时间损耗上
Lucia: So considering the previous time loss
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Haha
Lucia: 增加了100%的成本
Lucia: It increases the cost by 100%
Jake:呵呵好的
Jake: Hehe, okay
Lucia: 重点不在于绝对值
Lucia: The key is not the absolute value
Lucia: 而在于它的百分比
Lucia: But the percentage
Jake:嗯好的
Jake: Hmm, okay
Alice:看完两个
Alice: Watch two more
Lucia: 投资学告诉我们
Lucia: Investment studies tell us
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay
Jake:这个能带来什么收益
Jake: What kind of returns can this bring?
Lucia: 收益
Lucia: Returns
Lucia: 就是你的裤子会变干净
Lucia: Like your pants will get cleaner
Lucia: 也许吧当然还有一些风险
Lucia: Maybe, but of course, there's some risk
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Lucia: 就是没洗干净
Lucia: Like not getting them clean
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Lucia: 我们要尽量保持这个风险可控
Lucia: We need to keep this risk controllable
Lucia: 也就是说
Lucia: That is to say
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm-hmm
Lucia: 尽量不要把饭渣掉在自己身上
Lucia: Try not to drop food on yourself
Alice:老板
Alice: Boss
Alice:这几天为数不多的桌子干净的环节
Alice: These few days, the times when the table is clean
Alice:是不是都是我创造的
Alice: Weren't they all created by me?
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes
Alice:卧槽吓死我了
Alice: Damn, that scared me
Jake:这是
Jake: This is
Jake:这这没没说错啊
Jake: That's, that's not wrong
Lucia: 是哪一个
Lucia: Which one?
Jake:为什么掉下来了
Jake: Why did it fall down?
Alice:这个地是不
Alice: This floor, isn't it
Alice:是可以叫那个清洁的那个
Alice: Can we call the cleaning service?
Jake:对我在叫他们
Jake: Yeah, I'm calling them
Jake:不但是这个地我们其实
Jake: But this floor, actually
Jake:呃他今天明天都可以搞
Jake: Uh, they can do it today or tomorrow
Alice:那明天也行
Alice: Tomorrow is fine too
Jake:或者我们走了都可以搞
Jake: Or they can do it after we leave
Alice:只要反正
Alice: As long as, anyway
Jake:这个地不重要
Jake: The floor isn't important
Alice:只要你看着不难受无所谓
Alice: As long as it doesn't bother you, it's fine
Jake:嗯确实不怎么好受
Jake: Mm, it doesn't feel great
Jake:但是
Jake: But
Alice:但是可以装作看不见你可以不出来
Alice: But you can pretend not to see it, you don't have to come out
Jake:对
Jake: Right
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Jake:呵呵呵确实
Jake: Hehehe, indeed
Lucia: you should not pass
Alice:我妈就有点洁癖
Alice: My mom is a bit of a clean freak.
Alice:就是地上就拖的拖
Alice: She keeps mopping the floor.
Alice:拖完地之后地上有水痕反光
Alice: After mopping, there are water marks on the floor.
Alice:被他看见他都很难受
Alice: It makes her uncomfortable to see them.
Alice:然后他就老嫌我干
Alice: She always complains about my work.
Alice:就是干家务啥的就不细致说我邋遢
Alice: She says I'm not thorough with housework and calls me messy.
Lucia: 油没有可能说的是实话啊
Lucia: Maybe she's telling the truth?
Alice:啊确实是实话
Alice: Yeah, it's true.
Alice:我确实很邋遢
Alice: I really am messy.
Alice:然后但是我就让他
Alice: But then I tell her,
Alice:你就不能不看吗
Alice: Can you just not look?
Lucia: 我怎么觉得我上次搓的也是这条裤子
Lucia: I think I washed these pants last time too.
Lucia: 我的AI收集到最重要的数据就是
Lucia: My AI collected the most important data.
Lucia: 我经常来搓这条裤子
Lucia: That I often wash these pants.
Lucia: 他肯定会以为
Lucia: He must think
Lucia: 这条裤子对我来说有什么特别
Lucia: These pants are special to me.
Lucia: 特别怎么说呢
Lucia: Special, how to say,
Lucia: 独特的意义
Lucia: Unique significance.
Lucia: 我才会这么专心致志的洗他
Lucia: That's why I'm so focused on washing them.
Jake:他是看到这个裤子就要搓一会
Jake: He sees these pants and has to wash them for a while.
Lucia: 看到这个就
Lucia: Sees them and...
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Alice:看这个裤子要搓一搓
Alice: Sees these pants and has to wash them a bit.
Lucia: 不是最后他会建起这样一个链接吗
Lucia: Won't he eventually make that connection?
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 怪不得
Lucia: No wonder.
Lucia: 怪不得游戏里有那么多人工智障模型
Lucia: No wonder there are so many AI models in games.
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 我我我玩使命召唤五五的时候因为哎
Lucia: When I play Call of Duty 5 because, hey...
Jake:嗯嗯哎
Jake: Mm-hmm, hey...
Lucia: 你在哪里
Lucia: Where are you?
Lucia: 你在哈哈哈
Lucia: You are, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈环绕似的
Jake: Hahaha, it's like surrounding.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Alice:3D的 5D的
Alice: 3D, 5D.
Lucia: 我玩视频召唤5的时候
Lucia: When I play Call of Duty 5,
Lucia: 因为他那个比较老嘛
Lucia: because it's quite old.
Lucia: 他好多年前的游戏
Lucia: It's a game from many years ago.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm.
Lucia: 所以就有时候穿模糊穿的很奇怪
Lucia: So sometimes the outfits look really weird.
Lucia: 就比如说我把敌人炸死之后
Lucia: For example, after I blow up the enemy...
Lucia: 然后这个可以
Lucia: And then this can...
Lucia: 这个会啊
Lucia: This can happen.
Jake:没关系没关系啊
Jake: It's okay, it's okay.
Lucia: OK就我把敌人炸死之后
Lucia: Okay, so after I blow up the enemy...
Lucia: 没事反正是虚拟人物
Lucia: It's fine since it's just a virtual character.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 然后就是就是
Lucia: And then, like...
Lucia: 那个靴子就会浮起来在半空中停留
Lucia: The boots will float up and stay suspended in mid-air.
Lucia: 他没有落到地上
Lucia: They don’t fall to the ground.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Lucia: 就就那样卡在那里
Lucia: They just get stuck there.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Lucia: 然后我当时卧倒
Lucia: So then I lay down...
Lucia: 因为我害怕
Lucia: Because I was scared...
Lucia: 就是对方射击我
Lucia: That the other side would shoot me.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 我卧倒之后
Lucia: After I lay down...
Lucia: 我就看到刚被我打死的敌人的靴子
Lucia: I saw the boots of the enemy I just killed...
Lucia: 飘在我的面前
Lucia: Floating in front of me.
Jake:哈哈哈哈悬浮一个靴子
Jake: Hahaha, a floating boot.
Lucia: 好恐怖啊
Lucia: It was so scary.
Lucia: 对真的是悬浮一个靴子
Lucia: Yeah, it was really a floating boot.
Alice:哇哦you so勤奋
Alice: Wow, you are so diligent.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Alice:你把我的歌停了吗
Alice: Did you stop my song?
Alice:我靠神经病
Alice: Oh my god, you're crazy.
Alice:重新给你放吧
Alice: Let me play it again for you.
Alice:一到那就是卡壳
Alice: It gets stuck every time.
Alice:稍微扫一下吧
Alice: Sweep a little bit.
Alice:看着好难受
Alice: It looks so messy.
Lucia: 来扫吧我裤子脱好了
Lucia: Come on, sweep. I’ve already taken off my pants.
Alice:地上粘的像泥一样
Alice: The floor is as sticky as mud.
Jake:哎等会等会
Jake: Hey, wait a minute.
Jake:我这一圈相机没开所以
Jake: I didn’t turn on the camera for this whole round, so...
Jake:所以
Jake: So...
Jake:一会你先把这个扫把到门口等着
Jake: You can just sweep to the door first and wait.
Jake:然后我开
Jake: Then I'll turn it on.
Jake:我开一完之后就开始扫
Jake: Once I finish, I'll start sweeping.
Jake:好对
Jake: Yeah, right.
Jake:扫下有叫什么
Jake: Sweep down, what is it called?
Jake:扫把扫帚下牛垃圾
Jake: Broom, broom down the trash.
Jake:哈哈听
Jake: Haha, listen.
Lucia: 我要把扫把放到哪
Lucia: Where should I put the broom?
Lucia: 你刚说随便一个地方
Lucia: You just said anywhere.
Jake:就是进场的
Jake: Just bring it in.
Jake:进场就行了
Jake: Bring it in, that's fine.
Alice:虽然这个没有录但是这个不是录着
Alice: Although this wasn't recorded, it's not being recorded, right?
Jake:这个这个没问题
Jake: This, this is no problem.
Jake:对就开一下子
Jake: Yeah, just start it briefly.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice:好的那我可以嗑瓜子了吗可以的
Alice: Okay, can I start cracking sunflower seeds now? Yes, I can.
Jake:可以哈哈哈
Jake: Yes, hahaha.
Lucia: 可以往地下扔
Lucia: Can I throw them on the ground?
Jake:嗑瓜子哈哈哈挺好挺好
Jake: Crack sunflower seeds, hahaha, great, great.
Lucia: 哈哈哈给他多制造一下
Lucia: Hahaha, give him more to clean up.
Alice:我我不打地上哈哈哈
Alice: I-I won't throw them on the ground, hahaha.
Jake:等会等会你你一会再水滴润
Jake: Wait, wait, you can drip water later.
Jake:就是一会我们造成一个一一会
Jake: We can create a... later.
Alice:我我不扔地上
Alice: I-I won't throw them on the ground.
Jake:就是你一边嗑瓜子然后一边往地上
Jake: So you crack sunflower seeds and throw them on the ground.
Jake:然后就在旁边扫
Jake: And then sweep beside you.
Alice:知道吗
Alice: Got it?
Alice:这样会不会给我打上一个人品
Alice: Won't that label me as a bad person?
Lucia: 好奇怪的场景啊
Lucia: Such a strange scene.
Alice:人品低劣的标签
Alice: As someone with low integrity.
Lucia: 那你先嗑一会
Lucia: Then you start first.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 我再进来扫
Lucia: I'll come in later to sweep.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈要不然有一种
Lucia: Hahaha, otherwise it feels like...
Lucia: 就这两个动作同时发声就很奇怪
Lucia: These two actions happening simultaneously is very strange.
Lucia: 但如果发声完再发声就同时发声
Lucia: If one happens and then the other, it's still happening at the same time.
Jake:那就等会
Jake: Then just wait.
Alice:同时发生
Alice: Happening at the same time.
Alice:好像是我这人故意找点事什么的
Alice: It seems like I'm just trying to cause trouble.
Lucia: 哈哈哈那我跟你一起嗑吧要不
Lucia: Hahaha, then I'll crack seeds with you, how about that?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:来吧
Alice: Come on
Jake:等会再嗑喝等会再磕等会再喝
Jake: Wait a bit before snacking, wait a bit before drinking
Jake:忍忍一下忍一下忍
Jake: Just hold on, hold on
Jake:一下
Jake: For a bit
Alice:就不能一直磕吗
Alice: Can't we just keep snacking?
Jake:你可以啊你可以一直嗑
Jake: You can, you can snack all you want
Alice:来吧
Alice: Come on
Jake:来了我怕你嗑饱了嘛
Jake: I just worry you'll get too full
Alice:无所谓
Alice: It's fine
Lucia: 还有健胃消食片呢
Lucia: There's digestive tablets too
Jake:哈哈哈那你先吃
Jake: Haha, then you take them first
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Haha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Lucia: 人均造梗大师
Lucia: Everyone's a joke master here
Lucia: （歌词 ）执子手吹散苍茫茫烟波
Lucia: (singing) Holding hands dispersing the vast mist
Lucia: （歌词 ）已经太辽阔
Lucia: (singing) It's already too vast
Alice:小姐姐太勤奋了爱上了
Alice: This girl is so diligent, I'm in love
Lucia: 这算不算一种义工呢
Lucia: Does this count as a kind of volunteer work?
Jake:晚上吃点好的
Jake: Let's have something nice for dinner
Jake:怎么样
Jake: How about it?
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Sure
Jake:就到门口那个彩票店旁边
Jake: Just at that lottery shop near the entrance
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Alice:彩票在旁边吃狗
Alice: Eat dogs next to the lottery?
Jake:哎不对这是什么东西
Jake: Oh wait, what is that?
Alice:哎不对
Alice: Oh wait
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈是什么东西
Jake: Hahaha, what is that?
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Jake:哈哈吃什么
Jake: Haha, what do we eat?
Alice:吃狗店的
Alice: Eat dog food
Alice:小食
Alice: Snacks
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Haha
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Lucia: 我在家看家
Lucia: I'll stay home and watch the house
Alice:看门有我们的CP狗就可以了
Alice: Watching the house, we just need our CP dog
Alice:你刚给我们一起哈
Alice: You just join us
Lucia: 我给CP狗喂点吃
Lucia: I'll feed the CP dog
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Jake:昨天那俩不是卖了吗
Jake: Didn't we sell those two yesterday?
Jake:没带走是吧
Jake: They didn't take them, right?
Alice:没
Alice: No.
Jake:没有好嘞
Jake: Okay then.
Jake:净赚这黑店
Jake: Pure profit for this shady shop.
Jake:纯黑店这是
Jake: This is totally a shady shop.
Jake:哈哈哈近赚纯黑店
Jake: Hahaha, pure profit for this shady shop.
Lucia: 不是咱们的那个coin呢
Lucia: What about our coin?
Lucia: 上链那个coin不是说要
Lucia: Weren't we supposed to put that coin on the blockchain?
Jake:但是他们不是购买了吗对吧
Jake: But they purchased it, right?
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Jake:购买了商品应该带走
Jake: They should take the goods after purchasing.
Lucia: 之前不是说那个coin要就是
Lucia: Didn't we say that coin was supposed to...
Jake:对统计一下
Jake: Yeah, we need to count it.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Jake:但是统计的那个人发烧了
Jake: But the person counting it has a fever.
Lucia: 好吧
Lucia: Alright.
Lucia: 那我创建一个钱包吧
Lucia: Then I'll create a wallet.
Jake:哎可以等他
Jake: Yeah, you can wait for him.
Lucia: 不是我前两年
Lucia: No, a couple of years ago...
Lucia: 我前两年
Lucia: A couple of years ago...
Lucia: 前两年
Lucia: 那个就是NFT在国内刚很火的时候
Lucia: When NFTs were just becoming popular in China...
Lucia: 我之前是想
Lucia: I was planning to...
Alice:这是纸
Alice: This is paper.
Alice:黑色的纸
Alice: Black paper.
Lucia: what
Lucia: What?
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Lucia: 我那会是想创一个钱包了
Lucia: I wanted to create a wallet back then.
Lucia: 然后本来还有几个东西
Lucia: And there were a few other things...
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 我想试着上一下练
Lucia: I wanted to try putting them on the blockchain.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 但是最后让我放弃的原因是什么呢
Lucia: But the reason I gave up in the end was...
Lucia: gasp太贵了
Lucia: The gas fees were too high.
Jake:哦好吧对消耗太大对
Jake: Oh, right, the costs were too high.
Lucia: 对然后我就没搞
Lucia: Yeah, so I didn't go through with it.
Lucia: 但既然你们已经商量过了
Lucia: But since you guys have already discussed it...
Lucia: 那我就只需要创一个钱包就行了
Lucia: I just need to create a wallet, right?
Lucia: 创钱包又不要钱
Lucia: Creating a wallet doesn't cost anything.
Jake:对是的
Jake: Yes, that's right.
Lucia: 让我倒过来薅老板羊毛
Lucia: Let me turn it around and fleece the boss.
Jake:十年之后
Jake: Ten years later.
Lucia: 对谁知道呢
Lucia: Yeah, who knows?
Jake:买十十年之后把这套房子买下来
Jake: Buy this house ten years later.
Lucia: 万一10年之后
Lucia: What if in 10 years...
Lucia: 你成了下一个艾隆马斯克
Lucia: You become the next Elon Musk.
Jake:哈OK
Jake: Ha, okay.
Lucia: 那咱这个Coin不就值钱了吗是吧
Lucia: Then our Coin would be worth a lot, right?
Jake:那确实
Jake: That's true.
Lucia: 那我这个
Lucia: Then I...
Lucia: 不能错过这个初始股东的机会
Lucia: Can't miss this opportunity as an initial shareholder.
Lucia: 领导苟富贵勿相忘
Lucia: Boss, don't forget us if you get rich.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:哈哈哈必不会
Jake: Hahaha, definitely won't.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha.
Jake:相忘的至少
Jake: Forgetting at least...
Alice:这是个甲壳虫
Alice: This is a beetle.
Alice:你知道吗
Alice: You know?
Alice:这是他的尸体
Alice: This is its body.
Alice:刘婷
Alice: Liu Ting.
Jake:快了
Jake: Almost there.
Alice:开了吗快了
Lucia: 快我迫不及待的想扫地哈哈哈
Lucia: Hurry, I can't wait to start cleaning, haha.
Jake:还差一个
Jake: Just one more.
Jake:哎我去
Jake: Oh, come on.
Alice:你要听别的歌吗
Alice: Do you want to listen to another song?
其他人：行啊说吧
Others: Sure, go ahead.
其他人：嗯随便放吧
Others: Hmm, just play whatever.
Alice:你给我指定呗
Alice: You can specify one for me.
Alice:林俊杰
Alice: JJ Lin.
其他人：不要听腻了
Others: No, we're tired of it.
Alice:那你说名
Alice: Then you name one.
Lucia: 这个衬衣看起来真的特别舒服
Lucia: This shirt really looks super comfortable.
Alice:嗯棉麻的
Alice: Hmm, it's cotton and linen.
Alice:我平时听的
Alice: What I usually listen to.
Alice:你要让我跳歌我得跳半个小时
Alice: If you want me to skip songs, I could skip for half an hour.
其他人：这样
Others: Like this.
其他人：不过你那个歌单里面好说爱你好吗
Others: But that playlist has "Say I Love You", right?
Lucia: 说爱你好吗
Lucia: "Say I Love You", right?
Alice:行
Alice: Okay.
Alice:就放这这就这里的嗯
Alice: Just put it here, right here, hmm.
Alice:嗯呐
Alice: Hmm.
Alice:就是放那的无妨
Alice: It's fine to put it there.
Alice:一开始
Alice: At the beginning.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Alice:哈不是
Alice: Haha, no.
Alice:这次绝对进队了
Alice: This time I'll definitely make the team.
Alice:一开始哈哈哈
Alice: At the beginning, hahaha.
Jake:还有
Jake: And also.
Alice:什么受伤了
Alice: What, got hurt?
Jake:哎哎
Jake: Hey hey.
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh my.
Jake:即将开始
Jake: About to start.
Jake:哼哼哼哼挺好
Jake: Hmmm, pretty good.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Alice:干嘛
Alice: What?
Jake:好各位各就各位开始磕
Jake: Alright everyone, get in position, let's start.
Lucia: 哎怎么那天那个袋子还在这啊
Lucia: Hey, why is that bag from the other day still here?
Jake:哎稍等
Jake: Hey, hold on.
Lucia: 还没好吗
Lucia: Isn't it done yet?
Jake:对有一个他有问题
Jake: Yeah, there's a problem with one of them.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Got it.
Jake:就是这个
Jake: It's this one.
Jake:  拍个试试
Tasha: 嗯拍这个
Tasha: Hmm, film this.
Jake:哼哼
Jake: Hmm hmm.
Jake:走上楼
Jake: Let's go upstairs.
Jake:惨不忍睹是吧
Jake: It's a mess, right?
Tasha: 需要一个袋子
Tasha: We need a bag.
Jake:把这个电脑装起来
Jake: Pack up this computer.
Tasha: 怎么就剩了一个麦克风
Tasha: Why is there only one microphone left?
Tasha: 巴啦啦啦
Tasha: Ba la la la.
Tasha: 有可能我们首先需要一个垃圾袋
Tasha: Maybe we need a trash bag first.
Jake:大垃圾袋
Jake: A big trash bag.
Jake:但是呢
Jake: But...
Jake:在哪里会有呢
Jake: Where could we find one?
Jake:拿个箱子过来跟他们学怎么样
Jake: How about we get a box and learn from them?
Jake:你等着
Jake: You wait here.
Jake:你等着我去拿个箱子上来
Jake: Wait, I'll go get a box.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Jake:哎呀你好
Jake: Hey, hello.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Tasha: 就一个浪费
Tasha: Such a waste.
Shure: 我买了西瓜
Shure: I bought a watermelon.
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Jake:好谢谢
Jake: Okay, thanks.
Shure: 大家切瓜吃瓜吧
Shure: Everyone, let's cut and eat the watermelon.
Jake:好吃吃瓜多吃瓜
Jake: Okay, eat more watermelon.
Jake:音响收一收
Jake: Pack up the speakers.
Shure: 好的
Shure: Got it.
Shure: 那要镇上吗
Shure: Should we refrigerate it?
Shure: 那个西瓜
Shure: The watermelon.
Jake:huh
Jake: Huh?
Shure: 那西瓜要镇一下吗
Shure: Should we refrigerate the watermelon?
Jake:可以啊
Jake: Sure.
Shure: 怎么镇
Shure: How do we do that?
Jake:哎呀捡钱了
Jake: Oh, found some money.
Jake:这个小架子是哪来的呀
Jake: Where did this small shelf come from?
Tasha: 他房间的
Tasha: It's from his room.
Tasha: 哦你房间有个小架子
Tasha: Oh, you have a small shelf in your room?
Lucia: 对对本来是有个这样的小架子
Lucia: Yes, yes, it originally had a small shelf.
Lucia: 他实在是太难装饰好看了
Lucia: It was really hard to decorate nicely.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 然后我就换成一个小小的柜子
Lucia: So, I replaced it with a small cabinet.
Lucia: 给他铺了一个那个啥
Lucia: I laid that out for him.
Jake:OK OK
Jake: OK OK
Lucia: 这个我就拿出来了
Lucia: I'll just take this out.
Jake:太妙了
Jake: That's great.
Jake:然后给给薇薇用了
Jake: And then we'll give it to Tasha.
Lucia: 然后昨天刚好可以用来放甜点
Lucia: And then we can use it for desserts.
Jake:太妙了呀
Jake: That's brilliant.
Jake:这个应该也是记录了下来
Jake: This should also be recorded.
Jake:在你们俩的眼镜中
Jake: In both of your glasses.
Lucia: 对应该是我搬出来的时候
Lucia: Yes, when I moved it out.
Lucia: 我记得我戴眼镜了
Lucia: I remember I was wearing glasses.
Lucia: 因为昨天上午我一直在装修房子
Lucia: Because I was renovating the house all morning yesterday.
Jake:妙啊妙啊妙啊
Jake: Fantastic, fantastic, fantastic.
Lucia: 现在是不是又要该收拾一下
Lucia: Do we need to tidy up again now?
Jake:对二楼再收拾一下就可以
Jake: Yes, just tidy up the second floor and we're good.
Jake:就可以吃西瓜了
Jake: Then we can have watermelon.
Lucia: 好耶
Lucia: Yay!
Jake:宿舍买了几个西瓜
Jake: The dorm bought a few watermelons.
Jake:一个西瓜
Jake: One watermelon.
Jake:没有几个西瓜
Jake: Not a few watermelons.
Lucia: 几个西瓜
Lucia: A few watermelons.
Jake:一个西瓜
Jake: One watermelon.
Jake:没电了又
Jake: Out of power again.
Katrina: 没有刚充了半个小时还是只有17
Katrina: No, I just charged it for half an hour and it's still only 17.
Jake:啥时候买没关系
Jake: Doesn't matter when you buy it.
Jake:没关系
Jake: It's okay.
Jake:刮着什么了呀
Jake: What did you scratch?
Jake:刮到啥了呀
Jake:刮刮刮乐刮啊
Jake: Scratch, scratch, scratch.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 没买到
Shure: Didn't get it.
Jake:没买到
Jake: Didn't get it.
Jake:哈哈哈没买到是什么东西
Jake: Haha, didn't get it, what is it?
Shure: 所以就买了个瓜回来
Shure: So I just bought a melon instead.
Jake:为什么不开了
Jake: Why didn't it open?
Jake:倒闭了不是被人没
Jake: Did it go out of business or something?
Shure: 没去那家
Shure: Didn't go to that one.
Shure: 有一家更近的
Shure: There's one closer.
其他人：然后我就去那那家
Others: So I went to that one.
其他人： 结果发现他不卖刮刮乐
Others: Turns out they don't sell scratch-offs.
Jake:他只卖那种传统的那种
Jake: He only sells those traditional ones.
Shure: 打号的那种哦
Shure: The ones with markings?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Jake:镇镇镇一镇
Jake: Let's settle it.
Shure: 这没地了上楼上去
Shure: There's no space here, let's go upstairs.
Jake:那上楼镇一镇
Jake: Then let's settle it upstairs.
Jake:大伙吃瓜
Jake: Everyone, enjoy the melon.
Jake:刮刮乐没买到
Jake: Couldn't get the scratch-off tickets.
Jake:买了个瓜这
Jake: Bought a melon instead.
Jake:强一些应该
Jake: Should be stronger.
Shure: 帮忙
Shure: Help me.
Alice:这感觉
Alice: This feeling...
Katrina: 好啦这个是不是要搬下去了
Katrina: Alright, should we move this down?
Jake:好嘞三九几个呀
Jake: Okay, how many are there in 39?
Jake:上面应该5个吗 12345
Jake: There should be 5 on top, right? 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Jake:弄下去两个
Jake: Move two down.
Jake:这小马就放上面吧弄下去
Jake: Let's put the little horse on top and move it down.
Jake:哎一个house
Jake: Oh, a house.
Jake:对冰刮了
Jake: Yes, it's shaved ice.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Shure: 收拾一下
Shure: Let's clean up a bit.
Jake:要搬下去两个
Jake: Need to move two down.
Lucia: 啊怎么
Lucia: Ah, what?
Lucia: 他有影响到什么吗
Lucia: Did it affect anything?
Jake:他没有影响到什么
Jake: It didn't affect anything.
Lucia: 啊OK
Lucia: Ah, okay.
Jake:他就放了进去
Jake: He just put it in.
Shure: 你要扫楼是吗
Shure: Are you going to sweep the building?
Jake:对我要扫楼
Jake: Yes, I'm going to sweep the building.
Jake:他这个这
Jake: This thing here...
Shure: 这波的建模和上一波的建模有什么区
Shure: What's the difference between this batch of models and the last batch?
Jake:那你觉得有什么区
Jake: What do you think is the difference?
Jake:你你房间确实没什么区别
Jake: Your room doesn't really have a difference.
Jake:你房间可以不扫
Jake: You can skip sweeping your room.
Jake:哈哈哈什么
Jake: Hahaha, what?
Jake:你刚刚说啥
Jake: What did you just say?
Lucia: 我说这个就是如果影响
Lucia: I said, if it affects...
Lucia: 你可以放回我房间里
Lucia: You can put it back in my room.
Jake:不影响不影响
Jake: It doesn't matter, it doesn't matter.
Lucia: 因为我是在收拾
Lucia: Because I was cleaning up.
Lucia: 所以先把它拿出来了
Lucia: So I took it out first.
Jake:不影响不影响
Jake: It doesn't matter, it doesn't matter.
Jake:就是除了你的房间和厕所
Jake: Except for your room and the bathroom,
Jake:别的都有巨大的变化
Jake: everything else has changed a lot.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha.
Lucia: 这跟病例有关系
Lucia: This has to do with the case.
Jake:不是事实是这么回事
Jake: No, it's actually like this.
Lucia: 你是懂修辞的
Lucia: You understand rhetoric.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 我是不是有个卡子
Lucia: Do I have a clip?